في السابع من نوفمبر تشرين الثاني وبعد
نحو اسبوعين من انطلاق العمليه البريه
الاسرائيليه وصلت دبابات الاحتلال لاول
مره الى داخل احياء غزه وما هي الا ايام
حتى حاصرت مستشفى الشفاء لكن لم يخطر ببال
احد ان القسام اعدت تكتيكا خاصا سيلحق
الهزيمه بالقوات الاسرائيليه بعد
استدراجها بحسب راي الخبير الفلسطيني
بالشؤون الدوليه اديب زياده وحدث هذا فعلا
اذ انسحبت القوه الاسرائيليه من مساحات
واسعه بعد دخولها منها ساحه فلسطين فما سر
التكتيك الفلسطيني الذي هزم اسرائيل وكان
احد اسباب انصياعها
للهدنه مائ انحسر دوي القنابل في غزه مع
سريان الهدنه حتى بدا جيش الاحتلال يراجع
هفواته في حرب الاسابيع السبعه صحيفه يدي
عت احرنوت كشفت عن طرد ضابطين احدهما قائد
سريه والاخر نائبه انسحبت قوتهما في اثناء
معركه في شمال غزه بعد هروب نصف السريه من
منطقه الاشتباكات الى العمق الاسرائيلي لم
تذكر الصحيفه تاريخ الاقاله ولا المعركه
التي هزموا فيها لكنها اوضحت ان القوه
انسحبت بسبب تاخر الدعم الناري بعد وقوعها
في كمين نصبه عشرات المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
تشرح هذه الحادثه جانبا من التكتيك
العسكري للقسام في حرب غزه التي سقط فيها
حتى اليوم 300 و92 جنديا وضابطا منذ
السابع من اكتوبر باعتراف اسرائيل في
الاعراف العسكريه ثمت خمسه تكتيكات دفاعيه
هي الاكثر شيوعا في حرب المدن وفقا لموقع
جلوبال سكيورتي اتبعت كتائب القسام
التكتيكات جميعها وركزت اكثر على تكتيك
يعرف باسم نقاط القوه وهو استدراج القوات
المهاجمه الى منطقه معينه تكون محاطه
مسبقا بنقاط دفاعيه قويه ثم الانقضاض
المفاجئ عليها بهجمات متنوعه مثل الضرب
على اهداف مركزه او الصاق عبوات المسافه
الصفر مع امكان التنقل بطرق مرينه بين
النقاط الدفاعيه لاشغال القوات المهاجمه
وهذا ما يعرف بامكانيه التوغل البري لكن
استحاله البقاء على الارض كنا نقول ونؤكد
ان قوات جيش الاحتلال بما تملك من قدرات
وامكانات مدرعه وقوه ناريه تستطيع
الاختراق لكنها لا تستطيع فرض السيطره
وبالتالي هذه احد الامثله التي كنا نتحدث
عنها يتقدم يقع به خسائر يتراجع اما ثاني
تكتيكات القسام فهو اعداد الكمائن المحكمه
جدا ويقوم على تكثف الدفاع عن نقطه بعينها
لمنع العدو من المرور خلالها وتغيير مساره
الى نقطه اخرى يكون المدافعون لغموض ناسفه
وهذا حدث في الحرب الحاليه مرتين على
الاقل حسب ما وثقت معرفات كتائب القسام
حين تدرج جنود الى منزل مجهز مسبقا ثم
امطاره بالصواريخ والرصاص وفي الحاله
الثانيه فجر المقاومون الغاما بمنطقه في
اثناء مرور اليات حربيه اسرائيليه كما
يظهر هذا
الفيديو الله
اكبر وبالتوازي مع التكتيك العسكري
الميداني تشير تقييمات امريكيه الى ان
استدراج حماس للقوات الاسرائيليه ثم ايقاع
خسائر في صفوفها هو نهج يهدف الى اضعاف
التاييد الشعبي الاسرائيلي لخوض حرب طويله
الامد وذلك بحسب ما نقلت وكاله رويترز عن
مصدر مطلع في البيت الابيض ولعل هذا ما
يفسر الخطه الاستراتيجيه لحماس وفق تحليل
لمؤسسه سمسون البحثيه وهي انه عندما تخذ
حربا مع عدو يتفوق عليك بعدد الجنود
والتكنولوجيا وخطوط الامداد فسيكون
انتصارك في ايقاع اكبر قدر ممكن من
الخسائر وابطاء تقدم القوات المهاجمه لانه
يؤثر كثيرا في القرار السياسي بنظره
العالم اجمع الى تلك
الحرب